terry greater talk to you these are
really uh tense moments aren't they
these final moments potentially of a
release
can you take us back to to your
experience and and what you felt like
going through
what you thought hopefully was freedom
but presumably you you weren't gonna but
bet any money on it
well you're never out until you're
finally out of uh of that airspace
i remember many years ago when i was
bringing people home
from tehran who've been
imprisoned for quite a long time
we were driving to the airport
and we got to the airport
we went through all the checks
um
the plane came in
we were ready to board
and then suddenly
we were told
sorry you're not going
we all had to go back into tehran
and um
i took the issue up again with uh the
people who were holding us
i really got quite angry for the first
time for a long time
and eventually we did get out
but it was a very tense moment and
i just at the moment feel well
i'm so delighted as everyone will be
that netherland is now
at the airport so i believe
and i shall just breathe a sigh of
relief
when she's back home with her family
it is
incredibly cruel
isn't it to to get someone's hopes up
and then dash them so brutally and
clearly it's something that that
affected you and it wouldn't be the
first time that she's had her hopes
dashed would it
it wouldn't and uh
but the signs are good now that at least
she's got the airport
and um
for the past i mean it's been such a
long journey
um
six years since she was uh detained
um during that time
um
she and i have been able to
talk to each other we've spoken
on um
over the internet she's been able to do
that in the in the last year
we've been able to exchange emails
and there's not been a great deal that
she could say she's just been waiting
waiting waiting and i know what it's
like to wait you know i myself
had
five years in in captivity and soldier
confinement
in lebanon not in in iran
and one has to learn how to live one day
at a time
but it's been particularly difficult for
netherland because
of having a a young daughter who
um
and she said to me on many an occasion
she said you know my daughter's growing
up and i'm missing all those years and
again that's something i can
uh sympathize with and empathize with
because when i was taken my
son
was in his early teens
when i came out
he was a young man and do you know i
looked at him and
um i wouldn't have recognized him
the years have gone by those years have
been missed well you can make them up in
some ways but you can never recover them
properly
and she has lost something undoubtedly
but she'll make that up because she has
a very loving and caring husband
and
of course a daughter who'll be delighted
to see her
and i and i suppose in in terms of
timings technology has changed so much
in those in those years since you were
imprisoned and now with nazanin she has
at least as you say
been able to be in contact with
gabriella and with richard on on
on skype and on on video phones so she
she can see her daughter and her
daughter can see her at least that must
have been some comfort to her
yeah in some ways yes
it is a comfort to be able to have that
degree of contact
but i used to wonder about that myself
when i was you know in isolation
and it's a it's a mixed blessing to be
perfectly honest
because
you
see how um
someone whom you care for and love is
growing and changing
and it sort of heightens the experience
of
not being with them if you can
understand me
um
and i it's it's a mixed blessing but
it's it's been a help to i suppose on
the positive side it's been a help to be
able to have that degree of contact and
to be able to see
her daughter grow and
she's going to face now
um
difficult times in some ways because the
process of readjustment after being
separated
it does take time so much has changed in
the world
uh the family will of course her
daughter will have grown up
um they've been through all sorts of
experiences
and she'll need just to take time to
readjust um there's going to be an
enormous publicity and interest
and my advice to her at this stage would
be
you know make your one statement when
you come out
make your one statement
um to the press and then retreat for a
while and begin to build
your family life once again she'll do
that i'm quite sure she's a lovely
gentle kind person as many iranians are
and in terms of that recovery is as you
said managing the press when you when
you get back coping with the media glare
after being
away from it for so long um
and then the recovery itself coming to
terms with with what you have missed
what you have lost and how your life is
different
is is being held in captivity something
you can ever recover from do you truly
think
unquestionably you can uh
without a doubt um
i i've always believed that
you know suffering and you do suffer in
captivity of course you do
but i've always believed that suffering
need not destroy
within it very often you find
the seeds of something new and creative
and you can turn suffering round and i'm
quite sure
that that can happen in resident's case
that
of course there will be difficulties but
all sorts of new opportunities now open
up
she has a new depth of understanding uh
she was
you know very well versed in
in many affairs uh before she was
captured but she'll have a new depth of
understanding now
it can increase one's empathy
for people who suffer
um in my case it persuaded me to
give up my
regular occupation and to give my time
to organizations such as
hostage international which i founded
and
the homeless and so on
i wouldn't have had the courage to move
away from a salaried occupation um and
take my chance in doing what i did
without having had that experience of
deprivation so
creative things can emerge from
suffering uh if you have the right
attitude and i'm quite sure that nathan
has the right attitude and will make it
a creative experience but it sounds
crazy to say that but it's true
well anything that that gets you through
really i think
terry weight really great to talk to you
and thanks so much for giving us your
experience and it's great to know that
you've been in contact with her um and
that you feel that she will
manage and cope when she when she gets
out if she gets out today thank you
thank you